And what's next?
(audience cheer and clap)
Thank you, next up,
if you like drinking beers in the buff,
check out this pub in England.
"Food&Wine" reports, "A naturist, AKA nudist club
"in the UK called Nothing on events
"that just had its first pub outing
"at the Royal Oak in Surrey.
"People were encouraged to gather au naturelle
"for bruise in the nude, no shirt, no shoes, no problem."
Wait, so a nudist colony is like,
"Let's all get drunk together, that's our thing."
Is that what it is?
I think this is a no go for me.
I'm sorry, but I'm not showing you my pale ale
at this pub.
It's not happening.
And also, this is specifically at a bar.
I don't wanna be nude anywhere in public,
but I certainly don't wanna be nude and sitting
on a bar stool stool.
Where do you sit?
You know what I mean?
That's what I'm saying.
It's like, ooh, ooh, ooh.
Oh, you put a napkin down maybe.
A doily.
You put a napkin down.
Not for me.
(audience cheer and clap)
Would you do it?
No.
No, I would not do it.
What if you knew there was no cameras,
no one could ever record it.
It's just you and six of your closest friends.
Well, ironically, listen, I went
to a nightclub back in the day.
My friend, John would do this comedy act.
He was Dick Haney, the world's worst comedian,
and all he did was tell bad jokes.
And there was this club called The Blue Angel,
and I decided to get naked and walk around him.
And this was in the '90s so it was cell phone free
and you could get away with stuff like that.
So I don't judge it, but now, I could never.
So weirdly, I mean, I don't know.
Listen, I'm not judging.
I just couldn't do it now.
No, I'm no judge either.
If you guys wanna go
to this British pub
with your bangers and mash hanging out, go nuts.
I love the idea that it exists.
I love the idea that people are happy from it.
Well, and it was because of that Blue Angel story
that David Letterman's producer somehow found out about it
through word 'cause again, there was no internet,
no cell phones.
And that was the story they asked me to tell,
which then prompted me to get
on Letterman's desk and do my thing.
So I don't know.
I say you know what-
That was due to that?
Yes!
Oh my goodness.
Yes, and I had no idea what I was doing.
I was just so wild and free.
So I don't know, maybe.
Wow, a change of 180 immediately.
I guess that's why I wanted to figure it out,
different strokes, different folks.
You know what I mean?
I get it.
All right, well listen, clothes or nude, Ben Schwartz,
you are the most amazing gentleman.
It's just so fun hanging out with you.
Thank you.
I've never seen you naked so I wouldn't know
what it looked like.
It's basically this.
I've seen it.
Yeah, it's the same.
Naked, I look like Beaker from Bunson and Beaker
in "The Muppets."
That's basically what I look like.
I don't know Beaker that well.
Mi, mi, mi, mi, mi.
Mi, mi, mi, mi.
Well, I would Statler and Waldorf that anytime
and do commentary.
I appreciate it.
Ben, you are the greatest.
"Sonic the Hedgehog two" is in theaters everywhere.
I went with my kids.
We had the best time.
It's such a good movie.
There will be a third,
and I'm happy that you broke records
with that, congratulations.
Thank you, good to see you in person.
(upbeat music)